FACEBOOK:
What are the first words that come to
mind when you think of Facebook as a whole? Maybe
powerful, ubiquitous, and privacy intrusion? Now,
what are the first words that come to mind when
you think about OG Facebook platform? Old, dead,
out of fashion maybe? Well, you’re not alone.
This sentiment seems to be pretty common online
especially amongst younger generations. The
general theme seems to be that Facebook used
to be something that was popular back in the
late 2000s and early 2010s, but since then
it has largely fallen out of favor. And Google
trends simply confirms this idea. Interest in
Facebook today is only a mere 16% of what it used
to be back in 2012. So, it’s a good thing that
Facebook bought Instagram and WhatsApp and evolved
their business right? Well, there’s no arguing
that Instagram and WhatsApp weren’t stellar
acquisitions but what might surprise you is that
Facebook is still more lucrative than WhatsApp and
Instagram combined. In fact, OG Facebook is still
the most lucrative social media in the entire
world by a long shot. In 2023, for example,
Facebook is expected to pull in over $70 billion
in revenue. For perspective, YouTube only pulls
in $30 billion, TikTok only pullin $13 billion,
and Twitter only pulls in $4.7 billion. The only
platform that even comes close is Instagram at
$50 billion, but even Instagram is $20 billion
behind Facebook. And that’s just looking at top
line numbers. If we look at revenue per user,
Facebook becomes even more wild. It turns
out that Facebook still somehow has 3 billion
monthly active users, the highest of social media
platform. As such, there revenue per user is $23
per year. For perspective, TikTok stands at about
$8 per user per year and even YouTube only stands
at $11 per user per year. So, who exactly are all
these people who are still using OG Facebook and
how has Meta managed to keep Facebook so
profitable despite the overall sentiment?
OLD IS GOLD:
One of the biggest secret weapons
of Facebook is the time period in which it was
founded. At this point, it’s been nearly 20 years
since Facebook was founded which isn’t all that
long for a company but it’s basically eons for
a social network. In fact, Facebook is by far the
oldest social media that’s still relevant to this
day. Everything else from that era whether its MSN
messenger or MySpace are completely dead. Facebook
actually started off as a Tinder sort of platform.
Originally, it was called FaceMash and it allowed
Harvard Students to rate their peers in terms of
attractiveness. When you visit the website, you
would get two pictures side by side and you would
get to choose who was more attractive. Fun fact,
Zuckerberg actually almost got expelled from
Harvard due to FaceMash as Harvard felt that
the website violated their student’s privacy and
security. Sounds like somethings never change.
But anyway, Facemash and later Facebook was a
young persons website. I mean, I can’t imagine
any normal 40 or 50 year playing this game. But
here’s the thing, it’s not only Facebook that has
grown old over the years but all of it’s users as
well. If you were 20 to 30 when Facebook came out,
you’re now 40 to 50. And for the longest time,
this was actually seen a massive disadvantage.
To stay relavant, social networks are constantly
trying to get newer generations on board. YouTube
has managed to do a pretty good job of this given
that YouTube is commonly used by people of all age
groups. TikTok on the other hand very much skews
towards younger demographics as you would expect.
In fact, nearly 70% of TikTok users are under
the age of 35. Facebook, however, largely skews
towards older demographics. Their most popular
demographics is age 25 to 34 and nearly half of
all Facebook users are above the age of 35 which
is basically unheard of when it comes to social
media. But, while it may not be cool to have a
platform filled with people over the age of 35,
it’s turns out that it’s rather lucrative given
that this demographic is a lot more likely to
have money. In fact, for people under the age of
35, the median net worth is only $39,000. But,
when you jump up to 35 to 44 bracket, this over
triples to $135,000 and that’s just the median.
The average goes upto $550,000 and it only goes
up from there up until 75. And we see a similar
story when we take look at the income of people
using these platforms. With YouTube for example,
it’s actually less likely that you use YouTube
with growing income. 76% of people making less
than $50,000 per year use YouTube, but only 69%
of people making $50 to $100,000 use YouTube,
and 65% of people making over $100,000 use
YouTube. This isn’t to say that only broke
people watch YouTube but rather that YouTube
tends to be watched more by students and young
adults who don’t yet have substantial
income. With Facebook on the other hand,
there seems to be no correlation between income
and usage. In fact, whether you're making less
than $30,000 per year or over $100,000 per year,
there’s about an 86% chance that you use Facebook.
For obvious reasons, this is a much more valuable
audience to market to than teenagers and college
students leading to far more ad revenue for
Facebook per user than any other platform.
But all of that only tells half the story as
Facebook has an even more powerful secret.
AN EVERYTHING APP:
Every tech companies’ dream is to build
an everything app like WeChat in China, but most
efforts to do so in the west simply end up falling
flat. It turns out that people simply don’t want
certain things to be connected and that separation
is often not only useful but desired. In fact, one
of the main reasons that Instagram, SnapChat, and
eventually TikTok grew in popularity is because it
wasn’t connected to Facebook. Teenagers and young
adults are naturally not drawn to a social media
platform that their parents also use. But while,
Facebook hasn’t been able to create an everything
app across generations or across industries,
it does seem like Facebook has actually been doing
pretty well in terms of creating an everything
social media app for their core demographic.
Personally, I’ve never used Facebook messaging
and I don’t know even a single person who
does. Everyone I know just uses iMessage,
Instagram DMs, or maybe even WhatSapp. But it
turns out that messaging friends and family is
actually the number 1 reason that people use
Facebook. Amongst Facebook’s core demographic,
72% of users use Facebook for messaging
which is over 2 billion people by the way,
and that’s just messaging. 1.9 billion people use
it to share photos and videos similar to Instagram
and YouTube. 1.7 billion people use it keep up
to date with news and current events similar to
Twitter. And 1.6 billion people even use it to
watch memes and funny content similar to TikTok.
If you didn’t know, it’s not just Instagram that
has Reels, Facebook does too. So, it seems that
Facebok has created this sort of niche super
app that’s a combination of Instagram, YouTube,
Twitter, iMessage, and even TikTok that are all
super popular amongst the people who actually use
Facebook. This not only gives Facebook a lot
of control but also a lot of versatility when
it comes to ads. They’re not limited to any one
format like YouTube for example. Pretty much the
only control you have when it comes to YouTube ads
is how long the ad is and whether its skippable
or not, that’s pretty much it. Facebook on the
other hand is able to accommodate for image ads,
video ads, carousel ads, instant experiences, and
collections. Not to mention, they have several sub
formats under each of these larger formats. In
other words, on the advertiser side of things,
Facebook is able to appeal to all sorts of
advertisers, and on the user side of things,
they can push ads through all sorts of
formats. So basically, Facebook is super
popular amongst an older richer demographic that
use Facebook for all of their social media needs,
and advertisers are able to reach these
people through any medium they want. I think
you can start see just why Facebook is so darn
lucrative, but how sustainable really is this?
A SOCIAL EVOLUTION:
Having a rich older demographic that’s
loyal is great for the time being, but eventually,
these people will grow out of your platform right?
It’s no secret that as you grow older, you spend
less time on social media, the internet, and tech
in general right? Well, that has definitely
been the trend over the past few decades,
but correlation does not indicate causation.
Older demographics not using social media is often
chaulked up to people simply growing out of it,
but as we can see with Facebook’s demographics,
people don’t necessarily grow out of social media.
As such, I suspect that older demograhpics not
using social media actually has to do with other
aspects. First of all, people simply get busier as
they grow older. They’re working harder than ever,
they have kids, they have to maintain their homes,
and all of that. On average, people between
the ages of 35 and 44 have the least amount
of leisure time of any age group. But, after
this age, leisure time starts to grow once
again. People get to a comfortable position in
their careers, their kids go off to college,
they pay off their homes, and so on. By the time
that they’re 65, their leisure time is higher than
ever, and it seems that traditionally all of this
free time has just been filled with more TV. But,
I think a lot of that simply has to do with
lifelong influences. When baby boomers and
the silent generation were growing up, TVs were
just starting become popular and that stuck with
them. Similarly, as millennials and younger
gen Xers were growing up, social media was
just started get popular, and that may very well
stick with them. I mean, we can already see this
playing out. If you ask anyone under the age of
30 about Facebook, they’ll likely respond with:
who even uses Facebook nowadays. In fact, that’s
probably why a lot of you clicked this video, you
assumed that Facebook is on its way out. But it
turns out that over 3 billion people use Facebook
on a monthly basis, much of whom are over the age
of 35. Of course, their use of the platform has
evolved over time. They’re no longer ranking
whether their peers are hot or not. Instead,
they’re in Facebook groups with their friends,
family, and neighbors, and they talk about their
kids growing up or having to replace to roof
or local events. And I don’t think this will
change. In fact, as Facebook’s core demographic
grows older and starts having more leisure time,
they may actually start using Facebook even more
similar to how older generations started to watch
TV more. In other words, Facebook could very
well be the first social media platform that’s
used primarily by people in their 50s, 60s and
70s because for the first time, we’re seeing a
tech literate generation reach those ages. And
that’s not as far away as you might think. The
oldest millennials are about to turn 44 years old
meaning 50 is just around the corner. Social media
usage for people of the age of 65 for example
has already over quadrupled over the past decade,
and I think that number will only grow as newer
generations reach those ages. Now of course,
this doesn’t solve the problem of what
will happen to Facebook after millennials,
but what it does show is that Facebook may very
well stay dominant for a lot longer than anyone
expected. And in the meantime, millennials and
younger Gen Xers should simply get richer and
richer and have more free time to spend up
until retirement atleast. So, while it may
seem like Facebook is heading out the door,
it’s very possible that everything we’ve seen
so far is only half the story, and we’re about
to witness a social media evolution like never
before. With historically high interest rates, the
appeal bills and bonds is the higher than ever,
yet traditional brokerages haven’t really
adapted with the times. They still expect
people to use clunky bond tables, scroll through
long overwhleming lists, and even use virtual
keyboards till recently. And that’s why we created
our own modern bond platform: Silo. At Silo,
we prioritize the user experience and the ease of
finding and investing in the issuers you know and
trust, so that you too can lock in high yields.
Also, choosing a strong user experience doesn’t
mean sacrificing on safety. Every Silo account
is insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance and
$2.5 million in FDIC insurance. Also, all funds
deposited on the platform will be maintained by
our trusted custodian, Interactive Brokers, who
has experience managing $373 billion worth of
assets over the past 45 years. So, if you’re
looking for a modern way to invest in bonds,
please consider checking out Silo in the
description below. Facebook isn’t the only
Meta platform that killing it, Instagram is also
killing it. Check out this video to learn more.